OTTO SCHARMER: So good
morning, everyone.
I do feel this situation
has happened often
to me because I am from MIT.
And I don't know how often we
do also these live, global, very
ambitious things.
And you run into all the
fundamental problems.
And then, oh, what?
Really?
Is that true?
MIT, and you can't put
these two things together?
So I have been in that
situation also quite often.
So I want to share this
morning a few experiences
and stories around two guiding
questions that interest me
most.
One is how to use the power of
technology for good basically.
And as we all know, [INAUDIBLE]
and others from the Arab Spring
revolution, and so on, there
is with many people a sense
that social media is
good at breaking things.
But is it also good
at making things?
So that has been called into
question by social change
activists more recently.
So how to use technology
for good is one question.
And the other one is how to
use the power of mindfulness
not only for the cultivation
of the individual,
but also for the evolution
and transformation of larger
systems, of the collective.
So that's really
what's interesting me,
and the intersection
of these two questions.
So I want to also introduce
my colleague and co-creator
of U.Lab at MIT and the
Presencing Institute Adam
Yukelson, who on short
notice is in town
and is able to also join in
for the discussion later today.
So I want to start off
with-- I know no one can
see it, but maybe some remote.
So it's basically--
oh, we have it here.
Wonderful, we have it here.
So it's that kind of situation.
I just find it interesting,
and I'm sure many of you
have experienced that as well.
You go to other countries,
you go to other systems
and communities,
this kind of feeling,
a feeling of disruptive
change is true on many levels
off scale today on
an individual level.
Organizationally,
we face disruption.
Certainly, here in Europe.
I mean, no one needs
to explain that.
But also worldwide
with ecological
and social and other challenges.
So everyone is talking
about disruption.
That's no longer anything new.
What's the perspective we
take from the mindfulness,
or the term we
use is presencing.
And we mean by
presencing the capacity
of sensing an actualizing
emerging future possibilities.
So what's the
perspective we take?
The perspective we
take is that each
of us in each human system
and social system today
is not only sitting on this
side, the current reality
side of disruption, but
one part of ourselves
is also located here
on the other side,
in other words, which is kind
of representing the emerging
future.
In other words, we
operate on the assumption
that the future
is already there.
We just need to learn how to
notice it and pay attention
to it.
Because it's usually
not inside our bubble.
It's not in our main focus.
But it may be a
little left and right.
And that's a little bit
the topic I want to follow.
So the two ideas,
the two guiding ideas
we use, the first one, I'm
sure you have seen many times.
It's the iceberg model,
systems thinking.
10% is visible.
The other 90% also matters.
And so it's like on the
surface, we have symptoms.
Then there is structures
and systems underneath.
So for example, if we look
at the current situation
in Europe, you could
say symptoms is Brexit,
a lot of people disenchanted
with the European project you
could say.
Underneath, structures
and systems, a lot
of systemic disconnects, right?
If you look at the map,
the vote-- when was it?
Last week?
One way of interpreting
that is basically
representing inequity
in commitment
to do something about it, right?
So it's kind of the long
term results of the Thatcher
revolution that are
visible also in the votes.
So many people having the
feeling that the systems--
the bigger the system, the more
the mistrust and disappointment
because it's accumulated
in your life experience.
And we see similar patterns
in the rise of the Trump
phenomenon and the
rise of the right here
across all countries in
Europe, and similar phenomena
also in Asia.
But then, what's underneath?
What's driving?
So there's a number of
systemic disconnects
that I could-- the disconnect
between, for example,
finite resources and the
infinite growth paradigm.
So that's an obvious
one kind of related
to the ecological crisis.
But it's also a disconnect
between the real economy
and the financial economy when
there is something getting out
of sync.
And there is a disconnect,
also well-known,
between GDP and well-being.
For all developed
countries, more GDP
does not translate
into more well-being.
So it's no longer a good
measure for economic progress.
If it's not GDP, then what is
it, these kinds of questions.
But if you go a little
deeper underneath,
the next deeper level of
root causes, I believe,
has to do particular
with root causes that
originate between our
ears, that originate
in our qualities of
thought, particularly
the outdated paradigms
of economic thought
that we still use and
teach at business schools
and use to design economic
institutions based
on which way we operate.
So you can say thinking
creates the world in many ways.
And what we see today, the
enacted economic reality,
is really an embodiment
of yesterday's paradigm
of economic thought.
So when you look
at the evolution
of the economic thought and
the evolution of the economy,
you can see a movement
from centralized to free
market-- laissez-faire
capitalism-- to a more
social market economy like
20th century OECD countries.
And today, at the beginning
of the 21st century,
we move from this 3.0 economy.
We believe there's a possibility
of the current crisis
to progress to a 4.0 economy
in which the three sectors--
business, governments,
and society-- no longer
or just work against
each other, but begin
to work with each other
in order to innovate
at the scale of
the whole system,
addressing some of these
bigger issues like inequity
or connected to the
ecological crisis.
So that's, you
could say, the basic
view that we have been taking.
In other words, we see the
evolution of the modern economy
based on distribution of labor
and the evolution of economic
thought as an embodiment of
human consciousness that moves
from traditional
awareness-- like loyalty,
fitting in-- to
ego-system awareness,
which is what we still teach
at business schools today,
homo economicus, to
stakeholder awareness,
which is what we use in all
real companies or governmental
institutions today, to what we
believe will be foundation this
century, which is
ecosystem awareness,
by which we mean an awareness
that's not only focusing
on my well-being--
ego-system awareness--
or the well-being of the
few key stakeholders--
stakeholder awareness--
but that's focusing on the
well-being of all partners
in an ecosystem,
particularly those
that are least connected
and most disadvantaged.
The past 15 years,
I've done many projects
in sustainability,
education, health, business.
And basically, in
all these situations,
you face the same basic
issue that to make progress,
or the big challenges today,
no one can do it alone, right?
You need to bring together a
diverse group of stakeholders
that need each other
to make progress.
And then, once you
get that, you need
to help them to move from
a silo type of viewpoint
and interaction, or
ego-system awareness,
to ecosystem awareness, which
is a view that is more embedded
in the whole system view.
And that's basically
our bread and butter.
I mean, that's what
we have been doing.
And so let me quickly--
we developed basically
a method that is taking people
who want to engage on this ego
to ecosystem process, on a
journey that moves through
observe, observe, seeing
the system from the edges,
deep reflexion, rapid cycle
prototyping, like design
thinking, but that also
invites people to basically do
some inner leadership
work, which is basically
quality of listening.
So seeing your system
from different angles
doesn't help if
you still project
your old habits of judgment.
So the inner
leadership work that we
believe is necessary
today is basically
the development of
three inner instruments
of knowing that we call open
mind, open heart, open will.
And open mind
really means suspend
your old habits of thought.
Look with fresh eyes
into a situation.
Open heart really
means look at it.
So develop the capacity
to look at a problem
not from your angle, but from
the angle of your stakeholders,
from the partners
you're working with.
In all network
leadership challenges,
that's the number
one capacity that you
need to be effective in
situations like that.
And the third one, open will,
is basically the capacity
to let go and let come.
That's the reason why usually
mergers don't work, right?
It's because we hold on to
the old definition of us
versus them, and thereby
block an evolution to a new
we or a new kind of evolution
to connect to the deeper
sources of knowing.
So that's basically
what we have been doing.
There is a-- but I'm
not going into that
because as you can
see the pictures,
we have been using that
in a number of projects
in public sector,
private sector.
The bottom line
is you can do it.
It does work.
It takes a lot of effort.
But what are some
of the deeper shifts
that you can observe there?
And I think this
is a visible one.
So there's a little
summary slide here.
What we notice, if
you take systems
through a journey-- kind
of where you move basically
from the me to we shift--
where people begin across
organization and sector
boundaries to communicate
in a more fluid, in
a more direct way,
and therefore kind of develop
a more distributed intelligence
that allows people to
co-sense kind of what
the current situation is
like and develop ideas
and explore them quickly
with experimentation.
The main shift that happens
is not only outcomes
that you create, for
example, reducing
mortality and so forth.
But it's a mindset shift
that can be summarized
with this picture here.
It's a mindset
shift from this way
of seeing the
system as something
out there to seeing
the system that way,
which is a way that includes
myself as part of the picture.
So that's really at
the end of the day,
if you have a successful
process, that's
kind of the fundamental mindset
shift that, if in place,
allows you to be much
more effective in dealing
with issues.
And when you have a conflict
situation, a real conflict
situation, different
interest clashing,
to come up with productive
ways of dealing with that.
And when you move from
this mindset, the realities
out there, to this mindset
as an individual, what
do you call that?
What's the word for that?
What's the English word
that we use for that shift?
What do we call-- how do
we label the second state?
SPEAKER 1: It's
a transformation.
OTTO SCHARMER: What's that?
SPEAKER 1: It's
a transformation.
OTTO SCHARMER: Transformation,
yeah, transformation.
What other words for that?
AUDIENCE: Empathy.
OTTO SCHARMER:
Yeah, well, in a way
you could say it's like seeing
yourself as part of the system.
Often like there is empathy
with others, empathy with self.
Yeah, that's connected to that.
I think a lot has to do
with the term mindfulness.
And if you look at the field of
leadership, which is my field,
and you know like
I know everything
has been said too often by
too many people already.
So what is really new?
Very little things when you
look at the whole field.
But one of the things I
think that truly is new,
let's say the past 10, 15 years,
is the rise of mindfulness
from being a very marginal
term 10, 15 years ago
to being very central,
almost mainstream,
in four different areas.
It's in our cognition science,
health and well-being,
education, the whole movement
around social-emotional
learning, and now
the fourth one,
as you can see in [? Davos ?]
and other places-- leadership.
And why is it more than
maybe a personal interest?
Because this kind of capacity
to seeing reality out
there toward seeing myself as
part of the problem, of course,
is a key capacity that in
any kind of change process
you want to foster.
You want to develop.
So if that happens to a group
moving from here, this mindset,
which is like a [? deep aid ?]
when you have communication
in that mindset, and you move
to that style of talking,
that's dialogue.
Dialogue is not people
talking with each other.
Dialogue is the
capacity of a system
to see itself, to reflect
on your own assumption.
And yay.
You did it.
OK, wonderful.
So it's not quite synchronized
with what I show here.
But you know, it's
moving in that direction.
So making a system see itself
is not only, you could say,
a key feature of dialogue.
It's also 50% of all
change management
because if I see the system
out there, the problems we face
is because of all
these idiots around me,
all the other
departments, and so on.
And it's only if we
shift the way we talk
and the mindset that's
underneath to a way
where I am part of
the problem, where
I see how I in my way of framing
as contributing to the problem,
only then when you deal
with multiple stakeholders,
you start to having
useful conversation.
So in that regard, this
shift, this ego to eco shift,
really has to do a
lot with this capacity
to bend the beam of observation
back on to the observing self,
back on to making a
group not only sense,
but also see itself as
really the essence you could
say of systems
thinking and systems
thinking-based change processes.
So when we abstract
now from that and say,
OK, so that's kind
of where you could
say a shift in
consciousness is happening--
so if you don't like
consciousness, take awareness.
If you don't like awareness,
take mindset, or take the way
we pay attention.
Paying attention is
essential for all leadership
because energy
follows attention.
So wherever you
pay attention to,
that's where the
energy-- your own,
but also the energy of the
people around you-- is moving.
So we know that.
And what is
essentially meditation?
It's about paying attention,
about deepening and honing
our capacity to focus,
to pay attention
in a way that is not
diluted by distraction
by attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder
kind of symptoms.
So what does that look like?
So if we look at-- we
still cannot see it, right?
SPEAKER 1: Yes we can.
OTTO SCHARMER: Oh, we can.
OK.
So basically, we develop
social technologies
that is accelerating that
shift because usually, if you
go through processes, and making
a complex system sense and see
itself, and thereby
shifting the mindset
but also the communication
and collaboration in shifting,
that's a big thing to do.
It usually takes
a lot of effort.
So we developed
social technologies.
And I'll just show
you a few pictures.
This is a multi-stakeholder
group in Indonesia.
It's focusing on
one of the biggest
multi-stakeholder projects
currently existing.
It's Coral Triangle
Initiative, which
is the second most important
ecosystem after the Amazon
region on the planet.
And they map all the
different systems.
Now in our case, because we work
with a framework that we say,
OK, current crisis is ecological
divide, social divide, and also
a spiritual divide that has to
do with not really connecting
with our own deeper sources
of well-being and creativity.
So this guy in his real
life, he is a banker.
But the role he plays
here is Mother Earth.
So we bring the voice of
Mother Earth into this system.
That's the ecological divide.
We bring the voice of
the underprivileged.
Those are like the
fishermen, the farmer.
So bring also in.
And we bring the
voice of the emerging
future with the children.
So usually, you want
to map the system
in a way that's a little
more comprehensive than just
the existing stakeholders.
And that brings other voices in.
So mapping means
first comes reality,
and then morphing into
an emerging future.
So if we can switch one more.
So that's using the
same thing, but around
a different topic--
reinventing ICBC,
kind of the biggest state-owned
enterprise in China,
around big data.
So what it means for how
they relate to the customers,
to the other
communities, and so on.
So you can apply it to any
kind of problem of course.
But then, you try to take
a little more extended
stakeholder view.
Can I just do it?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, you can.
OTTO SCHARMER: All right.
So a different technique, which
is 3D modeling, which is you
model the system with objects.
And then you go around, and you
model first current reality,
then the emerging future.
In this case, it's all the
leaders of the various business
units with Alibaba
in order to use
it to map the interdependency
in their ecosystem.
So they do that.
And you know, it's 50 people.
It's maybe eight to
nine different tables.
And then, they look at the
patterns that emerge from that.
Here, the same technique,
but with 150 people.
So you can easily scale it.
And it just means that you
stay the same group size,
but then you make people
look at each other's results.
So you quickly, even
in a bigger group,
identify the key themes,
the deeper topics
that need to be addressed in
the second half of that bigger
workshop day.
So the last thing, the
main thing actually,
I want to share
with you is related
to the question of
technology and how
to bring these kinds
of processes to scale.
So we have developed these
other social technologies
that allow complex stakeholder
groups to go through this ego
to eco mindset shift.
We have done it many times.
Other people have done it.
So we all know it's possible.
But it takes a lot
of effort, right?
So the big question
on the table really
is how can you
bring that to scale?
And that's where, of course,
the question of technology
comes in.
And last year, we
launched an experiment
where I believe
for the first time
we're trying to link to things.
One is MOOCs, so the idea
of massive democratization
in the access to knowledge,
learning, and technology.
On the one hand,
now we know it has
been a success like
the last five year,
very interesting developments.
But learning stayed flat.
So learning and education
was in bad shape before.
Now it's worse because everyone
is just looking at the screen.
And how's transformation
supposed to happen that way?
So in other words,
it's working well.
MOOCs are working
well for the transfer
of technical knowledge.
It's not working at
all for developing
these deeper capacities
of innovation leadership.
So our question was can you
link these two things-- the MOOC
and democratization
on the one hand,
and the activation of the
deep learning innovation cycle
that I indicated before--
opening the mind, the heart,
the will-- on the other hand?
That was the experiment.
So we started that
early last year.
And I wanted to begin
with a little video clip
that we created for inviting
people into this space
because we knew the only
way of doing it successfully
is to radically decentralize
the space of learning.
So to move from one place that
you basically set up for others
to a radical decentralization
where people self organize
in their own communities.
All right.
I'm also showing the clip
because it takes into a tour
into MIT, into the
MIT architecture which
is a perfect embodiment of the
whole mindset based on which
not only education
today is organized,
but also all organizations
really, a tent to operate,
which is a distinction between
abstract knowledge at the top
and applied knowledge
at the bottom.
So that's kind of
the old paradigm.
And throughout that clip,
we'll share with you
that the big
disruption that's going
on in the space of learning
that really kind of
turns that whole
paradigm upside down.
So what this first
clip really did
is tell the story of
disruption that I believe
is currently going
on in the field
of learning and leadership,
which is two transformations.
The first transformation
is shifting the outer place
off learning from the
classroom, listening to folks,
to the real world,
learning by doing.
And the second
transformation concerns
shifting the inner
place of learning
from the head to the heart,
and from the heart to the head.
So a more, you
could say, holistic
that's not only
limited here, but that
includes the emotional
intelligence,
the relational capacities
on the one hand,
but also the learning by
doing on the other hand.
And what it really
is organizationally
is bursting up.
It's opening the old dome.
So the old model of
learning, everyone
is sitting inside that dome,
not a single window outside,
and you're captured inside
in these classrooms,
to a more open structure
where people can freely
move in and out.
And that's kind of what
the second clip is about,
which is inquiring more
into what really then
is the new architecture.
And so I want to briefly show
that one and then share kind
of the three main
learnings that we had
from running this
experiment last year.
This clip basically shows a
little bit the deeper evolution
of learning and action science
space that actually goes back
to the 1940s and Kurt
Lewin, who actually left
in the '30s Berlin when
the Nazis took power,
went to the east coast, and was
the main source of inspiration
of founding what today
is called action science,
which is the reason why I left
Germany 20 years ago going
to the east coast because
I wanted to learn that
methodology which starts with
the sentence that you cannot
understand a system
unless you change it.
In other words, as
a social scientist,
you have to engage with.
You have to participate
in the change processes.
Otherwise, you're just getting
stuck at the surface data.
You want to understand the
deep data that's underneath.
And that lineage, that
also includes the limits
to growth study
that in the 1970s
sparked the global
environmental movement.
And that brings us
now all the way here.
And I think the interesting
thing at the end
is what we see today
is that we see a deeper
personalization, the deeper
questions of awareness,
of mindfulness, we see as
very present in society today.
So here are the three
things that we learned.
So that was basically
these two clips we put out.
And we said, OK, if you are
interested in self-organizing
and activating such a deep
learning process for yourself,
join this experiment.
Create your own hub.
Here are the three
things that we learned.
The first one is that we had
quite a significant resonance.
So in the first
year, last year, it
was a total of 75,000
registered participants.
It doesn't mean that really
everyone participated
the whole thing.
So the hardcore, of course,
who did the whole seven-week
and then the seven-week
prototyping after that,
it's a smaller group.
But it is yet, even for
conventional measures,
a very significant group that
engaged in this process which
took many, many hours in
all these different places
to self-organize, to
form place-based hubs.
We were inspired by the Obama
campaign actually originally,
which is link technology with
local grassroots mobilization.
We wanted to do the same thing.
Create your own hub in
your own living room.
Invite your friends.
And form a group in your
company or in your living room
or your community
space that allows
you to go on that journey
together, not just alone.
And so here are a few pictures.
China, Chengdu, Mumbai, India,
Sao Paolo, and then Oakland,
Bay Area.
So it's a lot.
Not all of these
groups-- so these
were some of the larger groups.
But most of them were actually
much smaller, so five,
10, 15, 20, 30 small
groups that came together.
The second thing
that we learned is
that institutions--
so that's kind
of the bottom up grassroots.
But what was interesting is
that even in the first year,
we saw several
institutions using
U.Lab as a mobilization tool.
So in this case, Alibaba used
it for their own capacity
building, leadership
development.
Then Scotland used it-- the
Scottish government used it
as a way to reinvent
government from the old model
that we all know, which
is we create resources
that we give to our agencies
who deliver services
to beneficiaries.
The beneficiaries
are frustrated.
The front line people
who deliver the services
suffer burnout.
Now, that's the old model.
What they now try is
a different model,
what's called
asset-based, which is
you use the
resources to activate
the community themselves to
identify what they will like
to do, where the real needs
are, and then to co-generate,
to co-produce these services.
And they use U.Lab, the
seven-week self-organize
capacity building around
change initiatives
that they define as a
mechanism to mobilize.
So it involved more than
1,000 people last fall.
And this it is an NGO in China.
It's the number
one on reinventing
education in China
that partnered up
with us a few weeks ago.
We had a large meeting to
use that U.Lab approach
to massively bring innovation,
creativity into the education
system in China by bringing all
the communities, the innovators
of the education
system, together
and use the MOOC structure
to scale and accelerate
the replication
of what's working.
Now, the last
thing we learned is
that you could-- which is
maybe the most interesting--
that we could engage the global
community of tens of thousands
of change makers as a whole.
You see an example here.
So in each, we had
four live sessions.
In each of them, we use
global moments of stillness,
mindfulness practices, in which
the awareness was not only
focusing on your own body,
the field around you,
the local group you're
connected with, but also
the collective body of change
makers around the world,
across all these hubs that
came together in that moment
and started to interact
with each other, which
was a moment of
transformation and inspiration
for many as we
learned afterwards.
So we also engaged
the entire group
in knowledge creation processes.
So I'm not going
into details here,
but it's a one-page summary
of what the U process is,
which is the four
levels of systems
change-- micro, individual,
groups, organization system.
And on this axis, we have
four levels of consciousness
moving from downloading old
models to deep listening
and transforming
organization, transforming
the way we organize,
transforming
the way we coordinate,
basically from old style
to our emerging new, and kind
of more horizontal and more
co-creative in how our
coordination, collaboration
works.
Now, we asked people,
OK, that's the map.
Where are you operating today?
And this is what they set.
We basically operate on
the first three levels.
And then we asked,
given the challenges
that you face on all
these different levels,
where do you need to
operate from in order
to respond to these
challenges appropriately?
And this is what they said--
it's kind of the [INAUDIBLE].
When we saw that, we
asked them, wait a minute,
you just said this is
what you need to do,
this is what you really do.
Why?
What's holding you back
today on all these levels
to actually operate from
this more co-creative space
of connecting with others and
collaborating with others?
And here is what they said.
So we said give us your
response in three words.
And the word cloud that
resulted from that, it basically
can be summed up with greed,
fear, and ignorance, which
also in Buddhism is known are
known as the three poisons.
So that was at the beginning
of the seven-week journey.
At the end of the
seven-week journey,
we asked them, OK, now
that we have better
connected with what
you really want
to try to do, with your
life and your work,
what would it take for
you to actually bring that
into reality?
And this is kind
of what they said.
What I would take is courage.
And then we asked, OK, and
if you're really committed
to do that, if you
could mobilize that,
tap into that courage,
what is the help
you need from others to succeed?
And this is what people said--
love, listening, and trust.
So if you step back
and say, OK, what
is it that we learned from
our global community of change
makers is what
they really taught
is this-- that transformation
today happens around--
or leadership happens around
three transformations, which
is transforming ignorance
to listening and curiosity,
transforming greed to love
our empathy or compassion,
and transforming
fear to courage.
So it's these three
transformations
that we believe-- or that
little community of change
mirrored back to
us is really what's
at the heart of the current
leadership challenge
that we face not only
in small pockets,
but that we face if we start
to address the bigger system
issues.
In the exit survey,
we learned that those
that responded, a third of
them said life-changing.
So how could that
possibly be true?
Well, certainly not
by watching videos.
You don't have a
life-changing experience.
I mean, you're attached.
But it's not a
life-changing experience.
The only way-- I mean,
this is self-reported,
of course-- but the only
way that makes sense
is that the main experience
of learning that people had
was really facilitated at all
the self-organized groups.
And all the
self-organized groups
that met either in
person-- the coaching
circles, the place-based
groups that even met in person,
or using Google Hangout or other
technologies that made them
connect virtually which we
enabled through a platform.
So I started with
the question-- what
does it take to address
some of these processes
and challenges of disruption?
And what I basically said is
what it takes us two things.
One is a process, which
is-- OK, interesting.
So it's a process that
moves through these stages
of observing, of
connecting to sources
of knowing, and
prototyping, learning
by doing on the one hand.
And then the other to
make this process work
is engaged in this
inner leadership
work which has to do with
curiosity, compassion,
and courage, or open mind,
open heart, open will.
That's basically the
story that I told.
And I think that what we,
of course, also all see
is that in reality, often
the opposite is happening.
So this actually, when
you play it on the Mac,
it's actually looking
the other way around.
But never mind.
So it's the cycle of absencing
that I try to communicate here,
which is not this
process of opening
the mind, the heart, the will.
But it's the opposite,
which is what we see today
in larger scale
playing out around us
in corporate politics,
in larger systems.
In most systems
today, we collectively
create results
that no one wants.
And so that has to do with
ignorance, greed, and fear, as
shared before,
which means that we
are moving through a cycle
of denial, de-sensing,
absencing, disconnecting
with our true purpose,
and then kind of into a
process of destruction
as opposed to a
process of co-creation.
So that's basically, I believe,
the world we are living in
and that we see on the one
hand all of these processes
and networks of innovation.
On the other hand, we
also see lots of evidence.
We don't only have to
look to Donald Trump
to see the evidence.
The industry of fear, of
anger, and blaming others,
and of ignorance really
that is giving rise
to a lot of phenomena
that suggests
that in the current
evolutionary threshold
we're standing collectively,
we could move backwards very
easily.
I think that the interesting
moment we all live in
is that we actually participate,
or we have the possibility
to participate, in
that process where
the mainstream of our
evolution will either
tap more deeply into
this co-creative space,
or whether we kind of on a
collective level more and more
are sucked into this other
space which is really
fueled by the economies and
the industry of ignorance,
blaming others, and
anger, and fear.
So that's, I believe,
why the use, the heart
of this challenge has to
do with using technology
in a new way that is not just
amplifying this stuff here,
which we see in many all-star
networks going on today,
but that allows us to bring
these types of processes
here that we all know are
possible, and each of us
has already participated
in on a smaller scale,
to bring them to the
level of scale that's
really necessary today.
That's what we are passionate--
we'll love to partner deeper
with what you guys are
doing here in Berlin,
but also Google in general
in other locations.
And we think that--
my experience
is-- I mean, my first
Google visit, I remember
don't do evil or something.
I don't know
whether that's still
part of corporate culture.
But I think that there's
always at the heart
of the new technology
companies, there
is the aspiration making
the world a better place.
Yet, that's not
always what happens.
There's technologies also
used for this stuff here.
So what I would love
to learn from you
is kind of where
you see yourself
and how we can partner
more deeply to really bring
these types of new
environments to scale.
Because what we learn is the
openness of people, 75,000
people, joining up for
the prototype year,
that's a massive
amount of willingness,
but also our capacity
to self-organize
in completely new ways
and use technology
with more intention to form more
deeper and more dialogue-based
processes.
Anyhow, that's what we
are passionate because we
feel that the
technology-enabling conditions
that we have formed so
far are very insufficient.
Yet, they worked great.
But they are still
very insufficient.
The social media we have
now are mostly downloading,
kind of broadcasting stuff.
It's not activating these
deeper innovation processes.
To do that, we need each other.
And that's why we're here.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]